well hello boys and girls this is tim
ferriss welcome to another episode of
the tim ferriss show
where it is my job my privilege to
attempt to deconstruct world-class
performers from all different fields
my guest today is a writing
icon joyce carol oates joyce carol oates
is the author of novels
short story collections poetry volumes
plays essays and criticism
including the national bestsellers we
were the mulvaney's blonde and
a widow's story among her many honors
are the national book award
the pen america award the national
humanities medal the 2019 jerusalem
prize
and the 2020 sino del duca world prize
for literature
oates is the roger s berlin
distinguished professor of the
humanities at princeton university
and has been a member of the american
academy of arts and letters
since 1978. so that is the approved
bio there are a few other things i would
like to say though because
i think joyce certainly
is prone to understandably understating
her prodigious talents she is published
and again this is getting into
semi-non-fact-checked territory
but i think i do have most of these
right she has published around 60 novels
not to mention all the other formats and
genres she is so
prolific that in her wikipedia entry
there is a separate entry just for her
bibliography to give you an idea so
joyce carol oates bibliography is its
own
gigantic page her first book was
published in 1963
and i have read at least from two
sources
that on average she has had two
pieces of her work published per year
since
just let that sink in three of her
novels and two short story collections
if i'm getting it right we're all
finalists for the pulitzer prize
and her work is incredible i mean this
is just an endlessly impressive woman
endlessly impressive human endlessly
impressive
writer and teacher and with all of that
preamble
please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with joyce
carol oates one very quick note we had
some
wi-fi connectivity issues for the first
10 minutes or so
so please bear with us as we work
through that and then we were able to
change a few things and improve it
dramatically so might be
a little bit of touch and go in the
beginning but if you stick with it
we'll get to smooth audio pretty soon
thereafter
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e
i have had so much tea in my life i've
been to
china i've lived in china in japan i've
done tea tours i drink
a lot of tea and 10 years plus
of physical experimentation and tracking
has shown me many things
chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health
you name it i've been drinking fermented
poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now
poo air tea delivers more polyphenols
and probiotics than you can shake a
stick at it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why
peaks fermented puyer tea crystals have
become my daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them
through my friends dr peter atia and
kevin rose peak crystals
are cold extracted using only wild
harvested leaves from 250 year old tea
trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea and i alternate between the two
the rich earthy flavor of the black
specifically is amazing it's
very very it's like a a delicious
barnyard
very peady if you like whiskey and stuff
like that they triple toxin screen
all of their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic mold contaminants
commonly found in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea and that saves a
ton of time and hassle
so peak is offering fifteen percent off
their priorities for the very first time
exclusive to
you my listeners this is a sweet offer
simply visit peakt.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners of this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is
risk free one more time check it out
peak t that's p
i q u e t e a dot com slash tim
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn i've been using
expressvpn all the time constantly since
the summer of 2019
and i find it to be a super reliable way
to make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted without slowing
down
my internet speed whatsoever you don't
even notice that it's on
it's one of the best vpns on the market
and it couldn't be easier to set up
their flow
their signup flow is actually incredible
and i encourage everyone just to check
that out
all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone
and then use the internet just as you
normally would you click one button
in the expressvpn app to secure 100 of
your network
data one of the many reasons i use avpn
is that free to access sites
all sorts of sites that you use every
day make their money by tracking your
searches
or video history and effectively
everything you click on
and then they sell this valuable data
onto others when you use expressvpn you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you from hackers
and assorted bad guys on the internet so
if you're on
hotel wi-fi or public wi-fi coffee shop
wi-fi whatever
this is what i use so it's finally time
to take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com
tim by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra three months of expressvpn
service
for free again that's expressvpn.com
tim one more time expressvpn.com tim
to protect your data today
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i ask you a personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
joyce welcome to the show i wanted to
start
with a name that will be familiar
and that's jonathan safran four former
student of yours now a colleague of
yours who also happened to be
in my same class i believe
of the class of 99 at princeton as an
undergrad
and you wrote him a letter perhaps his
parents at some point but the way that
he recalls it there's a specific line
that i wanted to
to ask you about and we can take it any
direction you would like
and the line is this quote you appear to
have very strong and promising talent
coupled with that most
important of writerly qualities comma
energy and he then
later has come to strongly agree with
that
and man is she right energy is the most
important writerly quality
could you expand on what you mean by
that
i think it's sort of self-evident that
we need a good deal of energy to be
creative
we need a good deal of uh spirit and
kind of optimism
i think of it as kind of positive
delusions or
illusions about the worth of what we're
doing i was reading a biography of
walker evans this very distinguished
early 20th century
photographer and walker evans just makes
the point that
he would be asked like why is he doing
this and who's his audience
and he he said that he wasn't thinking
of that
he was thinking of the pleasure of the
camera
and seeing where it led him
and i think that's true of all created
effort
that there's a kind of spirit or like a
flame
it leads us somewhere to tell the story
it could be an entire novel to paint a
a painting of something extraordinary
that's never been done before
and be beyond that it's just the uh the
feel
that is the sheer pleasure in creativity
which is energy
and the opposite of that i think is
being interrupted many times
in situations professional or
familial where one is interrupted and
one's energy is drained off in different
directions
so that we don't have the concentration
that we need
that is really the great enemy of
creativity
if we're looking at maybe enemies is
would wouldn't be the right label in the
way that i'm going to use it but
obstacles as would-be writers perceive
them
i'd like to speak to getting started so
a
writer friend of yours i think with the
initials lm
uh you described as having remarked that
she'd like to be married and not
get married uh and
in other words and i'll i'll take some
liberty here but
not to find the perimeter the parameters
go through the growing pains of those
first few years but to be sort of
settled
in the existence of being married and
you likened that
to creative projects and writing
how do you overcome the the difficulties
or advise that students overcome the
difficulties in starting
a given writing project you could choose
the genre
well i think we're all very different
some people have a good deal of energy
and excitement in the beginning
and they can stay up all night long and
working on a novel
you know writing a complete short story
i think as we get older
we we sort of regard our energy
differently we don't quite
stay we don't stay up all night working
but parcel it out in a more reasonable
way
so it does depend upon who the person is
i have
i have writing students have a good deal
of energy
but i have others who have been working
on one one project for some time and so
they're kind of
focusing their energy but as i said the
one
the great adversary is being interrupted
and distracted
so distraction is our main adversary
right now
i think in in contemporary america
in the world of the internet and cell
phones
at the moment we have a kind of toxic
political situation that's very draining
of goodwill so all these distractions
make it difficult to concentrate
when you look back at your own creative
process i've read i don't know if it was
in the paris review it could have been
or elsewhere
in this series called the art of fiction
that
you need the title
and i want to say last line before you
being in writing
was that true or is there any truth to
that
was there at some point oh yes
i need to i need to see the ending of
the novel
i need to see it in a kind of cinematic
way
to sort of envision it and then i
i usually have some words to go with
that and i really need a beginning and
an end
and i need a title the title is what
brings it all together it's sort of like
a triangular
shape so the title will give you a sense
of what
the totality is the beginning obviously
is the precipitating factor
of the story should be in the first
line and then everything is a
consequence of that
and then the ending is the ending which
has been
you're moving toward that ending before
on page 19 or 99 or
199 you're moving toward that inexorable
ending
so you have a destination that is an
ideal way of writing
it may not be possible for everybody
some people like el doctro my friend
at doctoral he said that he never knew
how his novels were going to end
he thought it was like a car trip he was
he was driving along a road he didn't
really know where he was going
but i'm not like that how much do you
think about
structure so if you have the beginning
and the end
and the title even if it's
a placeholder i guess two questions do
the titles often change
after you've sort of decided upon what
you think it might be
and then the second is how do you think
about
or how much do you think about the
structure once you have
those initial points in place the title
could
definitely be changed it would probably
be an equivalent title
something that was the same tone
and the same symbolism but maybe it
could be a different word
i have changed titles a few times
ideally if you have the title first
then you have you have a vision so until
you work out the picture of a long work
it's not a good idea to begin however i
have begun
and i have made mistakes that i had to
correct as i went on
so much of writing like all art i think
is exploratory
we don't always know what we're going to
do but ideally if you have an outline in
the sense of where you're going it's
much easier
i spend a lot of time running and
walking every day i go walking or
i love to run and when i'm running
i think of my writing in structural
terms
have a spatial sense so if i don't go
running every day
my writing doesn't work as well it
really depends upon this kinetic
release and energy could you speak more
to
that is it an
active thinking about or considering of
the writing or
is it moving the body and letting
thematically loosely let's just say
in the case of structure pointed
consciousness just kind of bubble up in
the process of movement
could you just speak to running and
walking because i know it is a
seems to have been a huge part of your
life
what about you are you a runner i used
to run
i used to run i do a lot of walking so i
walk
and swim and bike i try to walk at least
a few hours a day
so i walk a lot yeah that's the same
there's a hill near
i live in a semi-rural area there's a
hill near
where i live a country road at the top
of the hill
i've gotten so many ideas i run over
there it must be about
that's about a mile or maybe mile and a
half
so it's like waiting for me on top of
that hill will be some idea
now that's obviously a mystical
superstitious notion on my part
yet it seems to happen quite often so if
i'm stuck
on a trying to work out a plot at my
desk i'm sitting right now at my desk i
really can't
work it out here i have to go somewhere
else
preferably up the baby on a hill and i
need to be alone with my thoughts
let's talk about uh
once you have set foot into this
exploratory process
of writing even if you have some
landmarks laid out ahead of time let's
just say the beginning
and the end actually before i hop to
that i'm going to ask you about revision
but when you say you have an idea of
where it ends or you know the ending
is it just a a concept
is it finished prose is it a finished
page is it a paragraph
what what does knowing the end
look like concretely it's pretty
definite
it's like knowing you get in your car
and you're going to drive to
san francisco and you want to go to san
francisco you don't want to wind up in
salt lake city
or you know so somewhere in montana
you're sort of aiming your vehicle for a
destination so
it's just sensible to plan that ahead of
time
if we look at then charting this path
and going from point a beginning
to ultimately z the end san francisco
like you said when you have an
initial draft i've read that you're
strongly in favor this is quote strongly
in favor of intelligent even fastidious
revision which is or certainly should be
an art
in itself how do you describe
the revision process to students
well i think a revision is so much fun
it's so exciting
to me the first draft is like material
and then the second draft the revision
is my
my use of that material
and so subsequent revision i revise all
the time
i'm revising a novel now i don't even
know how many times i've gone through it
i tend to write the first chapters over
and over and over again
and the second chapter is over again
then as i go on in the novel i get more
momentum so i'm going forward a little
more
fluently but yet when i come to my desk
in the morning
i definitely always revise what i did
the day before
and then i get a little momentum moving
forward again
but the revision is really like 99
of art i think there have been very few
artists who don't revise or
like visual artists may make sketches
they may do
several variants of the same scene
and apart from a real very small number
of
composers just could compose sort of in
their heads like mozart
and i guess chopin sometimes but then
chopin would work on
what he had he would he would work on it
anyway and revise it but i think mozart
was probably the most
spontaneous creator but almost nobody's
like that i mean beethoven worked very
hard
revising and just about everybody that
i've
ever heard of let's speak to
the revision process
i would love to hear in more specifics
if you're able
what you're looking for what you're
looking to take
out when you revise it and it is i'm
sure second nature at this point to the
extent that maybe it's hard to describe
but i'll give an example some
authors or writers look to
say first and foremost remove anything
that is confusing
could they could be confusing right or
that is
unclear that or they ask proofreaders to
help them
and ask them to indicate you know if
they had to
cut 10 or 20 what they would cut that's
involving other people but in your case
when you sit down
to revise could you walk us through any
of the
lenses you use to look at that draft
or the questions you ask yourself as
you're going through
is there any uh any level of specifics
that you might be able to offer
well it does it does depend upon the
manuscript
for instance if i'm working in a gothic
mode or a surreal
mode it's a different voice from
sociological realism
sometimes sometimes my writing is social
realism
and everything in the novel is authentic
it really happened
in some way if you go to that city you
can walk around
and see those streets there's a certain
pleasure
in that verisimilitude of the actual
world
james joyce who was in many ways a
surrealist writer
nonetheless he believed in in this the
beauty and sanctity of
of the of the actual so that
one can walk in dublin and sort of walk
through the you know the day of ulysses
and that's one way of writing there's a
poetry in realism
there's a beauty and just in things as
they are
however half of our maybe more than half
of our lives i spent
in dreams and in the unconscious so
that's a
surreal landscape every night we sleep
and the perimeters
of realism are dissolved you know with
great
great uh extravagant energy i think in
all sorts of images and improbable
things sweep into our minds when we're
when we're dreaming so i like to write
in a surreal mode
too and if i'm revising book of fiction
that's surreal
i consider that so very exciting because
each time i sit down to write or to
revise
i will get some golding
some nudging some hints something
surfacing from the unconscious so that a
sentence that may be relatively simple
by the time i revise it might it might
be a whole a full page long
because something else is is pushing at
it or pulling at it
it's like an octopus with many many uh
legs or
limbs or arms or anyway
the pull of the unconscious i think is
very powerful
and the more we can let that fuel what
we're doing
the more potent it is also the more
enjoyable
for the writer jumping back to
jonathan safran foer for a moment it's
on a website called identity theory it
probably appears elsewhere but he
mentioned that
you gave him a reading list
and i don't expect you to be able to
remember necessarily the exact
books or pieces of work that you
recommended that he read but do you
have any recollection of how you chose
what you did
well as i remember when jonathan was
very young he may have just
been a freshman at princeton he was
already an experimental
writer and artist as you probably know
his first book was this
joseph cornell compendium which he
he brought together which is most
unusual for a young person
to bring together work by by older
people
most young writers write their first
novel which is very autobiographical
but jonathan did not do that he he went
in a slightly different way
so i saw in him an experimental
personality and i like that myself
but most young writers should not be
experimenting
they should just write what they want to
write they may want to write about their
parents they might write about their
girlfriend or boyfriend or something in
the first person that's funny
you know that's droll or witty they may
want to write some satire
but by no means should they try to be
experimental because they're not ready
for it
whereas jonathan i think was never
really that interested
in replicating the actual world
he was more interested in experimenting
with the medium of writing which is
words
now i know that later on he has written
much more realistic
he's done autobiographical work he's
written pretty
transparently i think about his own life
and about
his marriage and family life
so i mean he has done it different kinds
of writing but because he had an
experimental
personality i probably gave him some i
probably gave him kafka to read i don't
remember exactly
what it would have been i want to stick
with jonathan just one more question and
then
move into some different areas but
jonathan also
mentioned and i'm paraphrasing here that
you were the first person to
take him seriously and
that you recognized there was such a
thing as his writing
his work so to speak right that he had
a work a body of work and development
that had never occurred to him
when did you personally first
have that feeling about
your own writing well about my own
writing
about your own writing no i probably
never had that feeling
i did have teachers who singled me out
and said very nice things to me
and i had a professor at syracuse who
even wrote a letter to my parents
and because he did that i did that for
jonathan also
i always remembered that it was a very
short
beautiful letter just that joyce is a
born writer
and she should be encouraged i can't
remember
the tales of it and i don't know if the
letter even exists anymore
i hope it's somewhere so i thought that
i would do that you know and when
jonathan came along i wrote this
i wrote his parents now i don't remember
exactly what i said but
mimicked that original letter so maybe
jonathan will write a letter
or has written maybe it's just something
we should a tradition we should
carry on but not overdue
so i don't i have not actually done it
since
just once it's quite a
quite an honor to bestow upon jonathan
he's
a very skilled writer
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
ship station the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff
online than ever before all of these
trends to e-commerce have been
accelerated due to covid and much more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products out
fast happier holidays for you and your
customers
shipstation takes the hassle out of
holiday shipping no matter where you're
selling
on amazon etsy your website via shopify
or other platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
large fortune 500 companies
it's no wonder that shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers
and right now my listeners that's you
guys can try shipstation
free for 60 days when you use offer code
tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
tim tim that's it go to shipstation.com
then enter offer code tim
shipstation.com make ship happen
as i understand it you're please correct
me if i'm if i'm getting the details
here wrong but your first
book was published in 1963 by
the north gate which was a collection of
short stories
was that impactful or important to you
or was just the act of writing and the
fact that you are so continuously
writing
more engaging more important than
that type of milestone would be for
many writers how did that affect you if
at all
oh of course it was very profound i was
just a very young writer
i had had a number of stories in the
best american short stories
and the o'henry awards so i had been
published in magazines and then some of
the stories were anthologized
so the next step would be a book and it
came when i was about
i don't i was about 22 years old i think
when i
received notice that my
manuscripts had been accepted so i
called my husband
at the time ray smith and told him about
this
he was at university and i was at home
and i was absolutely disbelieving i mean
i was so happy it was
i was overwhelmed i could hardly believe
it
and it was a it was of course a
milestone it's tremendously
encouraging i had
been encouraged earlier in in preceding
years by
various publications or winning an award
or something
so i've had been encouraged i try to
encourage
younger writers too i've endowed a
number of awards
fiction awards at different universities
for young writers
how do you encourage
young writers in your
classroom and that might sound like a
strange question but
you've had a lot of trial and error or
maybe just lots of trial i don't know
maybe it's mostly success
you've certainly been able to i'm sure
test a lot of things in the classroom
you've been able to see what students go
on to do
or how they gravitate to the craft of
writing or not
what if you found most important or
impactful
in terms of cultivating and encouraging
young writers most writers who are in my
workshop have already been writing for a
while
especially at nyu their graduate writers
graduate student so they know what
they're doing and they have a project
and they have their own stories
based on their own lives experience
imagination so
i'm a good reader i mean i'm a
sympathetic reader
and editor for what they're writing i
don't tell them what to write
we have a workshop situation where
everybody critiques
a submission for the day everyone has an
opinion
we have a conversation so it really
isn't just a professor
i have opinion and everybody else does
too
so that a writer a young writer might
feel well
they liked what i wrote but they didn't
quite understand it
or they thought it should be longer or
they thought it was too long
it's a kind of consensus of editorial
suggestions
in a typical writing workshop i i mainly
see my role as being a very sympathetic
and careful reader what does it mean to
be a sympathetic
reader well i'm not i'm not critical or
judgmental
i'm on the side of the writer i want to
see what they've done
i mean in other in other years like in
the decades past
there were male professors who told
women writers
that their subject matter wasn't
literary i mean even
had a well-known women writers who went
on
to become famous and win the pulitzer
prize they
they were discouraged by their by some
of these remarks
i would never think it and i would never
say those things
i don't consider anything that subject
for fiction if it's treated if it's
treated well
i try to get writers to write about what
they really care about
i read a a beautiful line from you
describing
a certain aspect of your creative
process and that is this is from the the
paris review
the art of fiction number 72 one must be
pitiless
about this matter of mood in a sense the
writing will create the mood
and you continue to say later in that
same paragraph
i forced myself to begin writing when
i've been utterly exhausted when i felt
my soul as thin as a playing card
when nothing has seemed worth enduring
for another five minutes and somehow the
activity of writing changes everything
could you expand on any of this i mean i
think it's it's pretty well put but i
know that there are
a lot of people who feel they need to
get themselves into the mood to write is
there
anything else you could add to this
no i i definitely feel that you create
your mood by
by working and i have a sort of work
ethic i come from the
part of the world where people did work
rather than just talk about it
and so if you feel that you just can't
write or you're too tired or this that
any other
just stop thinking about it and go and
work
i mean it's life doesn't have to be so
overthought
and you don't have to wait to be
inspired just start working
particularly i think first go for our
long run and a nice walk
and think about what you're going to do
come home and start working
but try not to be interrupted that's
that's the problem
most people are living in families or
they're living with a partner
and the other person has a schedule and
expectations
and while you may love your family they
can be the ones who drain your energy
for women that's always been a problem
women
are nurturing there's nothing wrong with
that
but women find it very hard to say no
women writers are always being asked to
do things pro bono
to volunteer their time to do different
things
you know to read manuscripts and to be
on committees and so forth
and the instinct is really to say yes
and i i say yes to
lots of these things but it's really if
you're a careful
custodian of your own time like philip
roth for instance or flow bearer
you would never give away a whole lot of
your time
philip roth would never he wouldn't do
one
100th of the things that i do he was too
smart he knew how to take care of his
to guard his own privacy do you
tend to work on multiple projects at a
time or when you're
immersed i've heard you describe being
immersed in a project and as soon as you
finish a novel you get assaulted by
all of these new ideas do you ever work
on multiple projects
at the same time no i usually focus on
my energy on one project
but i've been working on a novel right
now but i'm taking a little time off to
write a review
of a biography for the tls and i'm also
writing an introduction to
a new edition of dostoevsky's short
stories so i'm taking time off from the
novel
and then if i'm doing copy editing for
i've been going through a copyedition
manuscript for
another book that's coming out i'll take
you know a week off
from my novel to work on that part of
the reason i i
ask is i came across
a comment in the guardian and this is
not only in the guardian this is
certainly something i've come across a
few different times when doing homework
for this conversation
and that is something along the lines in
different places
the quote i don't have any anxiety about
writing not really
you know it's such a pleasure and our
lives are so relatively easy compared to
people who are really out there in the
world working hard and suffering that's
from the guardian
could you speak more to that again i
know it's like self-evident on one hand
but
also an uncommon contrast
to a lot of lamentations and
descriptions of anxiety around writing
by other people
difficulties writing writer's block etc
could you
expand on not having anxiety
around writing well i just don't have it
if i did i don't think i would want to
be a writer
i would have tremendous anxiety if i
were a performing artist like a pianist
and i had to give a recital
i would be overwhelmed with anxiety or
at least i think i would be i suppose
by practicing every day by by playing
you know three four hours every day you
get to a point where
the technique is just totally
totally internalized and you don't have
to think about it
and i would be anxious if i were an
athlete
you know competing with other athletes
right in
in real time with people watching you
know i would find that in
immensely anxiety provoking but writing
or
or painting drawing these these arts are
done
on our own time you can take as long as
you want
nobody's watching you nobody cares
either
it's a very different medium as i said i
i find it anxiety producing
to even imagine playing piano in front
of
an audience i did that once i i wasn't
i took piano lessons for quite a while
for about 11 years and i was playing
i would be the student who played the
piano when the students
marched into the assembly in my
middle school and so i actually did this
and it wasn't too bad
but being on a stage performing
in front of people who know the music i
would just find that overwhelmingly
terrifying
is it the real time that's my dog
barking in the background if
if you can hear that but uh is is it the
real time
nature of that the necessity to deliver
in front of an audience in real time
versus being able to
take your time without people really
necessarily paying attention or caring
is that the
largest distinction between those two oh
yes but
some some pages and my novels i've
rewritten so many times
so there would not be any one time
that anyone could watch anything like
that you know
i think when really good professional
musicians are playing
they're probably replicating what
what they've done before i know actors
almost ex exactly and precisely do the
same
the same performance night after night
so they've sort of it's internalizing
their brains
and they just have to go through it
another time
but with writing every time i
every time i look at a page i can revise
it
there has to come an end to this
eventually you just have to stop doing
it you know
but in theory james joyce could still be
working on ulysses and finnegan's wake
because he was like that he was
experimental and every morning you wake
up with some new ideas and you could
write
you could write another another novel
the whole different
novel would come out of your your mood
that morning
but we can't allow ourselves to do that
that's just too fantastical
how do you decide when something is done
or
when you need to stop because you could
just continue
otherwise indefinitely i try to use
common sense
i'm going through a novel now that i've
gone through probably 10 times
it's in the computer so i i go through i
scroll through it
and i'm still changing it and changing
sentences
i'm taking out paragraphs i'm moving
things around
but this has got to be the last time
because the novel is coming out in
august
so the time is left i've been working on
it for
a year off and on and it has
metamorphosed quite a bit from the
beginning
the main structure was always there in
the main characters but the sentences
the sentences always change but i'll be
done with that by monday so then i'll
send that to my
my editor and i'm not going to change
that
anymore looking at 10
tips of yours for writing i believe
these
were originally tweets at one point
it's uh like i mentioned a list of ten i
want to ask about
a few of these and if any of these are
incorrect please correct me
number one is write your heart out
number four
is keep in mind oscar wilde quote a
little sincerity is a dangerous thing
and a great deal of it is absolutely
fatal
and then it goes on but could you
explain why the oscar wilde quote
about sincerity well yes he's being
funny i think he's recoiling against the
kind of
deadpan overwhelming boring
rectitude that one encountered in the
victorian
world where literature was seen as a
vessel for ethics and
for morality so it's a lot of preaching
there used to be a good deal of
preaching
and didacticism
in prose fiction and he was probably
relating to that so
that kind of sincerity is just
it's just very boring i mean one doesn't
want to hear
much of that literature should be
interesting i should i think it should
be dramatic
and characters should be colorful and
unusual and
each sentence should be as original as
possible
and then write your heart out is
something that vernon bernard mullen had
said
i'm really quoting him it's just right
you know right
and right and right and don't don't hold
back
so joyce i would love to ask you about a
few more of these and then we
we can move on uh the number three
in this this top ten list is you are
writing for your contemporaries
not for posterity if you are lucky your
contemporaries will become posterity
could you expand on that please this is
probably aimed for people who were
english majors and who were
reading the great classics you know if
you're reading paradise lost or
the great place of shakespeare or
middlemarch or ulysses you're
overwhelmed
those audiences also no longer exist so
you're writing for your own time you're
writing for your own generation usually
maybe people a little older than you are
and then people younger than you are
but basically the audience that that
revered paradise loss is long gone
so this probably doesn't even have to be
told to people
in in the year 2021
that's mainly it that you're writing for
your own time
sometimes people are writing to impress
a parent
sometimes people are trying to be
outstanding and
distinguished to impress someone who's
not even living
any longer could be a parent
you know people have many unconscious
motives
but that these can be impediments and i
think there's a natural voice
if you think back on your own experience
as a writer
are there any impediments short-lived or
long-lived
that come to mind for you
well i think i was a little
self-conscious at the beginning to write
very freely and openly because my
parents would read what i wrote
so i may have been a little inhibited
but i tried
i definitely tried to overcome that or
to ignore it
otherwise i wouldn't have been able to
be a writer
but i did begin writing under different
names
one name was j.c smith
so i had married raymond smith so i used
jc smith
as a name for a while and then was j.c
oates
which not necessarily a woman kind of
androgynous
person and finally just settled on joyce
carol oates
though for a while i had a couple of
pseudonyms but they were women
they were women's names and
why did you decide to use this the
pseudonyms
was that to sort of preempt any type of
criticism directed at you was it a
creative exercise
did it give you more liberty in your own
mind
to push to the edges what uh why why did
you use the pseudonyms
the first pseudonym was rosamund smith
and i had probably been writing about 20
years
so i wanted to embark upon a new voice
with a different focus these were more
suspense novels rather like
movies cinematic and in movement
and structure without without much
exposition or background
not as much description each chapter
seen in a movie moving forward these
were totally different
and so i just wanted to have a an
outlet for a sort of imaginative writing
that wasn't so much in the mainstream or
my con
my usual writing my conventional
or whatever my own writing is it's a
little more
main maybe mainstream and this was more
like
suspense psychological suspense snapples
number eight on these this this top ten
list this will be the last one
uh on the list that i'd love to hear you
expand on and it is don't try to
anticipate an ideal reader or any reader
he she might exist but is reading
someone else
what does don't try to anticipate an
ideal reader
i think it's pretty self-evident just
there's an
integrity to the work you have to
express the work
and you shouldn't be curtailing it or
shaping it to
impress some person so when you
write you do not have any reader in mind
it is really just
a creative process for you
and you alone well this the the work
itself has its own integrity
you have to express the word each work
is different
i mean if you think of one novel of mine
they're all they're really quite
different from one another they're
totally different and the voices
tend to be different they're different
in each novel
so there'll be no way that i could be
writing for one audience or
i'm not i'm not really thinking of an
audience
can you suggest any one novel of mine
that that you've read that
you might have a particular question
about like the tone or
the voice because i can't think so much
in abstract terms
sure yeah no it's it was more a question
of
of when you work on any given piece if
if you ever think of
sort of who it is targeted towards not
to necessarily curtail your
creative boundaries so to speak i just i
i think of it
in contrast to something i know i'm much
more familiar with which is non-fiction
fiction i i really have no experience
with whatsoever but in in the world of
fiction
thinking about just as an example
what levels of expertise you assume
in your audience right as a way of
determining
how much terminology you need to explain
or omit
or include to make it compelling and i
mean this this
i guess just makes me think of say john
mcphee writing about
geology right it'd be it be very easy
to lose the reader depending on how
close you zoom in on some of the the
details
of something like that so it was really
just a broader question now let me talk
about that you see you've just suggested
a particular work he wrote that for the
new yorker he was working with william
shawn
who was an editor who wanted many many
details and everything had to be very
authentic
and the fact-checking at the new yorker
is is famous you know they're very very
careful
so john mcfee writing for the new yorker
he would write a certain kind of
of work if he were working if you were
writing for a
tv guide you know or time magazine or
the new york times book review
would have been very different that's a
good example of non-fiction of aiming
for a particular market
so john mcphee would be given like the
whole issue of
the new yorker for one of his long
non-fiction pieces and it was tailored
for that magazine and then they all
became books and
some of john mcphee's essays are really
classics i mean they're wonderful so
writing for the new yorker for him was
perfect
somebody else may be writing for you
know a pulp magazine and
one is criticized for having a complex
sentence structure
but when john mafia was writing for the
new yorker
and other people write for the new
yorker for non-fiction and i have
written
for the new yorker reviews and essays
you definitely are aiming for a certain
kind of reader
but that's a little different from
fiction fiction
is in its own world and has its own
voice
and i don't usually think of there being
a particular audience for fiction
how do you give assignments or think
about
giving assignments to students
well i can reach in my drawer and look
at some of these assignments
i've always given assignments to
introductory writers
so i teach on different levels i'm
teaching advanced fiction
at rutgers this semester and i taught in
the graduate
writing program at nyu and they're all
older students
but at princeton sometimes i have taught
introductory writers so i give them
assignments
they want assignments they're very happy
to have assignments
and their and the assignments really
work very well i'll see if i can find
some and just read some
perfect we have a textbook and so i
assigned stories for them to read
and for instance one one assignment is
to write
to introduce a character to read a
number of stories which i have assigned
in a mythology
might be a story by margaret atwood and
story by james joyce william faulkner
and then to write just a page where
they're introducing us
a character and then at the end of the
introduction they have the character say
something so that's not really a story
they don't have to worry
they don't have to worry about writing a
story they're just doing something very
basic
and then in another assignment i have
them write
a piece that's like a memoir very short
it doesn't have to be a literal memoir
but it's
like a memoir like something that
happened
when i was six years old when i was 10
years old last week
then another assignment which is very
difficult for the students and i
often don't give it unless i think the
students are
are up to it it's a
mimicry of prose style first
example is to write a few pages in the
style of hemingway
and then write the same story again the
same material again
in the style of jack kerouac
and then finally in the style of hp
lovecraft
now that's an assignment as i said i
don't always give
because it's demoralizing for some
students they just cannot do it
so i i didn't give it recently i
probably gave it a couple years ago
when i have good students that's
assignment's terrific
they really enjoy mimicking hemingway
and and writing a little hemingway short
story
and they really enjoy jack kerouac and
they find lovecraft very challenging
but it's sort of like with music if you
have
gifted pianists you could give them
assignments and they will do well
others are just hopeless and demoralized
so i try i try to measure the
assignments according to the aptitude of
the students
but then one assignment that i always
give the last
assignment in the course would be to
write a short story that turns upon a
moral
decision some ethical or moral decision
in somebody's life and they do very well
with that
young people have a natural moral
instinct and they're they're interested
in morality
and they want to know what's right and
what's wrong
and i have other assignments too i mean
many i have many different assignments
and what one of them i i did recently at
uc burke
we read shirley jackson's a lottery and
instead of writing a critique of the
story i said if you want to
you can write a little story from the
point of view of wanting to carry in the
lottery
a minor character and so they did
wonderfully with that
how much of your writing
have you if for lack of a better term
thrown away uh finished writing could be
short story could be a poem could be
anything
or never looked at once you finished it
unpublished
i i i'd come across mention of
i believe you sort of tucking away or
getting rid of
a fair amount of at least your early
work do you have any
guess on or or commentary on on how much
of your finished work
never gets shown to anyone else
well now i probably publish everything
that i do when i was younger and had
more material
sometimes i just didn't like something
and i would
take it out of circulation now in the in
the other room
i could show you a huge stack of short
stories
and those are stories that were
published in magazines but i never
gathered them into a book those go back
for years
and maybe one or two of them even won
some award like the oh henry award
but i never felt that i really wanted to
put them into a hardcover collection
for one reason or another i'm not sure
why
but there they are there are many of
them there probably about 300
400 pages
they'll never be published this is also
a
segue and really just have a handful of
additional questions
i could keep going but i think just a
few more would be really
fun for me this leads to a question
about productivity or it's really a
question about a comment that i've read
of yours on productivity
and that is productivity quote
productivity is a relative matter and
it's really insignificant what is
ultimately important
is a writer's strongest books it may be
the case that we all must write many
books in order to achieve a few lasting
ones just as the young writer or put
might have to write hundreds of poems
before writing his first significant one
do you have any additional comments on
the relationship between
volume of
writing and enduring quality
or if you want to take that question in
different direction you could as well
but do you have any thoughts
uh thoughts to add to that well it's
it's inevitable
if a number of books some books have
come to seem traditionally more
important than others
that is inevitable if dh lawrence wrote
a good deal he's
a brilliant short story writer but
probably only a few of his short stories
tend to be anthologized
you know over and over same with
faulkner
and with hemingway too hemingway wrote
many many short stories
but you'll see the same two or three or
four stories
reprinted quite a bit there are probably
jane austen novels that are
you know pride and prejudice and emma
and then you get to mansfield park
not as many people would read that same
with shakespeare measure for a measure
just not as popular as hamlet
it's not as important to play but it has
wonderful things in it
try this in cressida is a fascinating
play
of shakespeare but if you're only going
to teach two or three
plays of shakespeare you would not be
teaching troilus and cressida
you would be teaching macbeth and learn
and
hamlet and maybe othello those are the
ones that come to the surface
but the other place of shakespeare i
mean every one of them even titus
andronicus
they have much to them he is always a
very remarkable
playwright so if i've written 50 novels
not all 15 novels are going to be
admired by by everyone or by anyone
that's just not the way it is so some
things just seem to come to the surface
and maybe there's a perversity somebody
might prefer faulkner's
the hamlet to faulkner's the sound and
the fury
they might prefer sanctuary to light in
august
but again with faulkner he wrote a lot
and
some of it is considered the most
important writing in american
literature in the 20th century but
usually just two or three or four titles
you you have an incredible body of work
novels short story collections poetry
volumes plays essays criticism i mean
the the list is extensive the
the number of publications even more so
for someone listening
if they have no familiarity with your
work do you have
any recommended starting points i know
that
you could you could probably just as
easily pick any number of
of different uh pieces of your work but
are there any that that come to mind
offhand as
places if people want to get an idea and
appreciation
for the range
of your work well of course that depends
upon what they're looking for
i have a long novel called blonde which
is about the
the private life really the interior
life of marilyn monroe
norma jean baker the person who became
marilyn monroe
but that novel is about 800 pages long
and so some people might feel that's
just too long
that's one of my favorite novels of my
own but then i have novellas that are
only like 180 pages long
pursuit is a new novel that came out
last year
it's really um almost like a novella
it's a short novel
it's probably only about 200 pages
that's a novel that's more like a
suspense psychological suspense novel so
that
it's a mystery and you're not really
sure what has happened until the very
end
so if somebody might prefer a much
shorter novel that's
driven by a plot blonde which is about
marilyn monroe
is not really driven by a plot it's it's
her life
her complete life i've selected details
from her her life but the main parts of
marilyn monroe's life
are treated in great detail in that
novel and then i have an
of them which is based on my own
experience living through the civil
disturbance or riot
of detroit in july 1967
so if you read them you're plunged into
detroit in that era
and it's a family novel some people like
family novels
and i love family novels myself and i
write them too
many of my novels are family novels
they're about families and
usually starting with the older
generation and then
ending with the focus on the younger
just kind of shift
in the novel from one generation to the
next generation
and often my novels will in the very
final
page or paragraph is in
the province of the younger a younger
member
of uh we were the mulvaney's was an
oprah selection so that's the novel
that's
more people have read me without even
the mulvaney's
than any other novel of mine because it
was an oprah selection so
it's sort of guaranteed i think like a
million copies will sell
in the past it may not be quite like
that now with oprah's book club
and i have a novel that's sort of about
the um
you know the vietnam war i mean the
different subjects and i have many short
stories that are
gothic like the haunted haunted short
stories
tales of the grotesque the corn maiden
these are collections of short stories
that are that are surreal or gothic
horror literary horror some of them have
won awards
for uh like the bram stoker award for
for literary horror
are there any particular whether it's
short stories novels or otherwise
of yours that there's so many
elements that go into the publication
and release of a book sometimes
things get just overwhelmed by the news
cycle there could be any number of
things
happening at any given point in time are
there any pieces of work that you have
published
that you are particularly proud of
that you wish had received the same
or a higher degree of attention right
you you so you have we were the
mulvaney's like you mentioned that was
an an oprah pick and boom all of a
sudden you've got
a dozen reprints of uh this particular
work are there any others that
that you're you're particularly proud of
and wish
had slightly greater visibility when
people are citing the better known works
of yours
well that's hard to answer my novel
middle age or romance came out the week
of 9 11.
so that was a disaster but there was so
much in the world that was really a
disaster you know in a tragedy that
somehow books books of fiction didn't
seem that important
at the time writing has a way of making
its own
it makes its own way somehow i think
there's a set of consensus what remains
in your mind to be done i mean you've
done so much
many people would argue and have argued
many lifetimes of other writers you've
compressed into your own
in terms of uh work what are the
uh the items that remain to be done if
if any
or does that does that just simply not
enter your mind
as a as a question is it is it really
just continuing with the craft
as you have no i guess i don't really
think in those terms it's sort of like
dreams
we may have had thousands of dreams but
yet when we fall asleep tonight we'll
have one you know
have a succession of dreams tonight are
waiting
so it somehow doesn't matter that you've
had dreams in the past
you know it's the kind of novelty and
originality and the intensity and
urgency
of the of the new story and the new the
new dream
the new novel we always have stories to
tell
and we are evolving all the time
and we're discovering things as we get
older our perspective starts to
change we start losing many people when
you start losing people in your own
family and people who have been
close to you your parents help to define
you
so when your parents pass away you start
to be a slightly different person
and many people who are older are
thinking back over their lives
and they have a new perspective so they
may want to write a memoir
women who lose their husbands are so
traumatized by that
was sometimes led to to write memoirs
i wrote a widdle story which i would
never thought
i would never wanted to think i'd be
writing but i did write that
so you were asking who you know if
somebody wanted to read my writing where
would they begin well
some people like memoirs so i've two
memoirs
widow's story which is very raw and
immediate
based on my journal of the first three
months of being a widow
which is the most painful grief it
starts to diminish a little bit after
that
but it never really goes away but and
then a more of a
full lifetime memoirs the lost landscape
a writer's story sort of looking at my
looking at my life from the perspective
of being a writer but looking at my
parents and
the farm that i lived on and many people
have read that memoir and they can
identify with it
well joyce this has been so much fun for
me
thank you for writing your heart out
certainly i
think you exemplify that and
i would love to just ask if there's if
there's anything
else that you would like to say to those
people
listening any closing comments or any
requests
of my audience anything at all well if
you are if anyone is listening as a
writer i think
you basically just have to do a lot of
reading and read what you like to read
and read for pleasure and often it's a
good idea to read a number of books by
the same writer
like when i was in high school i just
fell in love with faulkner
and i read virtually everything of
faulkner so i was like the only person
in my age group who was reading faulkner
but that really helped me immeasurably
later on i went through a dh lawrence
phase
a nebulkov phase i read a lot of
hemingway
i read a lot of virginia woolf this set
of like phases that you go through
if you're a writer that's very natural
and very good
just go out and buy all the paperbacks
you know of virginia woolf and just
spend
a few months reading virginia woolf it
will change your life completely
i love that that is excellent advice i'm
doing that with barry lopez right now
oh he's wonderful just incredible yeah
just recently passed away but what what
an amazing amazing amazing human being
an amazing writer
uh joyce i really i i did not have the
opportunity to interview him i
actually read of wolves and men which
so impressed me and i
then started to look into reaching out
to him and i found out he was in hospice
and
he he passed away just a week into my
reading
of wolves and men just a few weeks ago
yeah
that's so sad how old was he he was
uh i'm not going to hazard to guess
i mean he he wasn't he wasn't
extraordinarily young because i know
that
i mean he must have i'm just imagining
that he was probably my age
when he published of wolves and men in i
want to say 1978
i'm 43 now so
so he wouldn't have been yeah i think he
would have been
been older but i i believe i believe it
was
cancer i can't recall the cause but but
just getting acquainted
with barry and reading i'm about to
start his memoir or what you might
consider a memoir
it's really wonderful i mean i do feel
like reading his collected works
could really change how not
not just how i view the craft of writing
but how i look at life
just the lens through which i look at
life and
your work has done that for many people
as well so
i uh i want to thank you for that thank
you yeah that's what we all hope for
yeah okay well goodbye
yeah thanks so much joyce hey guys this
is tim again just a few more things
before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the the world of the esoteric
as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by expressvpn
i've been using expressvpn all the time
constantly since the summer of 2019
and i find it to be a super reliable way
to make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted without slowing
down
my internet speed whatsoever you don't
even notice that it's on
it's one of the best vpns on the market
and it couldn't be easier to set up
their flow their signup flow is actually
incredible and i encourage everyone just
to check that out
all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone
and then use the internet just as you
normally would you click one button
in the expressvpn app to secure 100 of
your network
data one of the many reasons i use avpn
is that free to access sites all sorts
of sites that you use every day
make their money by tracking your
searches or video history
and effectively everything you click on
and then they sell this
valuable data onto others when you use
expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address that makes your activity
more difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you from hackers
and assorted bad guys on the internet so
if you're on
hotel wi-fi or public wi-fi coffee shop
wi-fi whatever
this is what i use so it's finally time
to take back your online privacy at
expressvpn.com
tim by visiting my special link you'll
get an extra
three months of expressvpn service for
free
again that's expressvpn.com
tim one more time expressvpn.com tim
to protect your data today
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e
i have had so much tea in my life i've
been to
china i've lived in china in japan i've
done tea tours i drink
a lot of tea and 10 years plus
of physical experimentation and tracking
has shown me many things
cheap among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health
you name it i've been drinking fermented
poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now
poor tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to
find real poorer that hasn't been
exposed to pesticides and other nasties
which is super common that's why peaks
fermented puyer tea crystals have become
my daily go-to it's so
simple they have so many benefits that
i'm going to get into and i first
learned about them
through my friends dr peter attia and
kevin rose peak crystals
are cold extracted using only wild
harvested leaves from 250 year old tea
trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea
and i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a
a delicious barnyard very peaty if you
like whiskey and stuff like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic molds contaminants commonly found
in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea
and that saves a ton of time and hassle
so peak is offering 15
off their priorities for the very first
time exclusive to
you my listeners this is a sweet offer
simply visit peakt.com
tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners at this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is
risk free one more time check it out
peak t that's p
i q u p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a dot com slash tip